the jurogan experience i kind of wish
i had that with like a wife that's why
i'm so scared of marriage
because you changed so much from just
high school to now or college to now
and then you get them you get married
and then you change again maybe when
you're
62 and then you stuck with this uh
plus-sized lady and you don't know what
the hell to do and how to get out and
you can't meet anybody new because
you're 62.
that's the problem with the contract of
marriage right that's the problem is
that it is a legal contract
it and it feels goes great very
antiquated it is
in a lot of ways um it's very good for
uh ensuring that there's like uh
there's a bond that's not just your word
yeah
you know it's legal so if you do try to
leave the woman at least has some sort
of financial recourse
in some case the men every now and then
one of us
we put one on the board right tom arnold
is our all-star
right lebron made money from
divorces he's the goat yeah i think it's
like when a black cop shoots a white guy
i'm sure it's the same [ __ ] with the
black community or
like when oj won i i lived in a black
neighborhood and i could hear the
yelling and people were going nuts
yeah every now and then a guy wins who
else do we know of that has
made money off of like a high-profile
divorce where the woman had all the
money there's a new one that just came
out with a
actress that just divorced a guy and he
was a nobody and he's cleaning up but i
can't think of who it is
yeah give that a good jamo i i don't
know how you would look that up but
yeah how do you look at that guy killing
it with hot actress wife
yeah i don't know but there it is oh
kevin fetterline
yes oh though kevin got fat
like he decided [ __ ] i'm gonna get fat
he was hot
he was a hustler handsome i think hunker
burned love he had a six-pack and looked
great
yeah hot wigger what is uh is that what
he look like now
i don't know now he's very big oh there
he is the bottom right yeah he's a
chubster
he got very big it's not so bad though
not too bad got a little
gut there oh yeah oh jesus that's
christian never
oh my god he was that big look at the
clothing bro he got big
but also you know he's taking care of
the kids under lost dress
true true it's funny how all that stuff
rolls that rolls out the window when
it's like when the tables flip
you know it's like hey women need their
money and then when the guy's like i
need my money it's like oh what are you
doing you're like well that's what
you've been doing
you know it's like how come when it
flips now you're mad
ah i'm a [ __ ] you see what i'm saying
but uh
i don't wanna have to get into it this
is great coffee do you think that uh i
mean
it's just they're non-traditional roles
right and when a woman is killing it
and she's uh making that money there's
uh an understanding
that more women have been [ __ ] over by
men okay
well that that's probably true it is
yeah it has to be
the beatings it seems natural right like
when you think about it like the woman
gets the money like
yep yeah seems natural but if you think
about the man gets the money
like you're like what why does he want
the money it doesn't feel right right it
feels wrong
which is so cool about comedy because
those things are imprinted in people
so when you make a joke the wrong way
you make a fat guy joke ha ha
make a fat lady joke no no right and the
audience will tell you that and so all
the pc
all the tweets all the [ __ ] you can
tell me this [ __ ] all day but i got a
focus group right here
dude i saved uh a body positivity meme
that someone tried to
get out there a pot for men with guts oh
yeah
it was like a fat men your body's
beautiful
right like like get the [ __ ] out of it
they were trying it but you know this is
not gonna work it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work yeah it only works
on females it's true it's true
big is beautiful it's never about chris
christie
you know it's about lena dunham or
whatever exactly exactly well there's
you know it's it's and it the feeling
that they're getting from this is a
supportive feeling
from other females men would never
support you for being a fat
[ __ ] never never never they're never
like yeah bro
who cares man you look awesome with your
fat gut
like never which is actually healthier i
mean it's a little meaner out of the
gate but at least we're being honest
we're keeping it real uh yeah or we're
not letting them get away with something
yeah there you go i mean that's what i'm
saying your friends if they love you
they're not gonna let you get away with
that they're like bro you are fat as
[ __ ]
yeah and you're like no really like look
exactly
yeah and that's a friendly thing yes you
know like if i had a fat
son and corona was hitting i would be
like hey man
like i don't care what you look like you
can do your thing and eat all the
chocolate you want but
i'm worried you'll get hit with the
coven more because you're fat
and you will and you will statistically
and then you're like hey you can't talk
to him like that that's bob i'm like i'm
worried about my son [ __ ] you
he could die if it's if it's a woman
you'd be body shaming
but when they try body shape they try to
say it's body shaming on a man it
doesn't really stick
right it doesn't it doesn't stick it
doesn't stick it doesn't stick yeah
what's going on here
kelly clarkson's x that is the one that
was the one brandon black stock seeking
six figure monthly payments wow six
figures how long are they married
he wants 5.2 million a year a year
a year he also requested clarkson cover
two million dollars in attorneys fees oh
my god
wow oh my god that's insane
he's killing it that's insane black
stuck
but here's the thing the difference is
there's a there's a great difference
seven year marriage that's great in a
year but
here's the is he taking care of the
children
uh-huh do they have children together
that is the question 135 of the 436 was
for child support
he needs child support money from her on
top of the three-hole one and
she's probably on the road a lot you
know she's a singer was he like the
manager
or some [ __ ] was it one of those deals
because those deals get real tricky
mm-hmm when the the man becomes the
manager and then it's very difficult for
the woman to get away from
the manager yeah in boyfriend girlfriend
deals with the girlfriends of singer or
and
husband wife when the yeah or the dead
well google says he is an american
talent manager so
oh there you go you called it if there
was any question that some of those
[ __ ] are weasley those numbers
yeah show you yeah definitely just to
request that
oh my god you want how much i know
all that management joe jackson was a
psycho and i think uh jessica simpson's
dad was a real weirdo i never obtained a
license to uh
legally operate as a talent agent
according to of course not he was
[ __ ] the client he didn't have to
yeah there you go
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on
spotify watch back catalog jre videos on
spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience